My name is Paige. I started doing
machine learning a long time ago. Um
around 2009 2010. Um was primarily
working with um though it feels like
forever ago. I was just talking with a
friend about this recently. Um, back in
2009 2010, it was kind of wild that
companies would even trust open source
software to do business critical work.
Um, and so I was contributing to things
like numpy, sci-fi,
like little like little antenna these
microphones. Um,
>> yeah.
>> Sure. Cool. Cool. Um so numpy, scypi, uh
mapplot lib, which is still just as
excruciatingly painful to use. Um uh
scikitlearn, kind of the early days of
the scientific computing stack. Um and
eventually started working as an
engineer. Um my background is geoysics
and applied math for undergrad and then
computer science and carbonate geology
for grad school. And so I started at
Chevron doing work in subsurface
geocciences
um doing a lot of things like velocity
modeling, drilling optimization using
very very basic machine learning models
um and uh also some large scale compute.
So, if folks in the audience um also
have gray hair like me, you might
remember Cloudera uh which was one of
the first companies that made some of
the open- source uh frameworks and tools
available um for consumption of like
Fortune 100 companies. Um so things like
Spark um a lot of the data bricks team
came from the Cloudera world. Um and so
I was spinning up clusters of machines
there. Um eventually TensorFlow got
released in the open source world around
2015 towards the end of it. Um and I
started contributing to that. Um the
geocciences world is really big into
GPUs. They were even into GPUs before um
the machine learning world and um so so
I had experience working with CUDA and
and all of the the associated tools and
TensorFlow when it was first released um
only supported CPUs. I'm not sure how
broadly that's known, but uh but it was
like distributed deep learning across
CPUs and they needed somebody to help
with like getting GPUs
um to to work with TensorFlow. Um that's
also why there are three different code
paths in the original TensorFlow 1
framework um because they had to like
gut the backend and replace it for CPUs,
for GPUs, and for TPUs both for single
node and for distributed computation
across multiple nodes. Um, so that's
basically it. Like I owe my entire
career to open source software um, and
open source models. And I I got hired at
Google for specifically that reason. Um,
and then I left to go work at GitHub for
about a year on VS Code, which is also
open source, um, and early user
experience testing for C-pilot, and then
came back to work on our large models.
Um, and so I was part of the original
Palm 2, Gemini, and Gemma teams.
Yep. So that is journey. I'm not sure.
Like I said, I'm not sure. It's
interesting.
>> You need to leave soon. You said to have
a
>> Oh, uh 4 4:15 because I've got meetings
uh we have leadership team meetings from
like 4:30 to 5:30.
>> Yep. And Gon will be here. And then also
potentially uh potentially our colleague
Ian will come to uh will come as well.
>> Potentially because I say something
hours. I think I think there will be
there will be like enough good stuff.
>> Yeah. Like if you're if anybody's
curious like open source is a great way
to like work with the team to figure out
if you would want to work with them and
then also make sure that your public
>> I'd love to show you my
>> guess how many stars you got.
>> Wow. Excellent. Good job.
>> I'm catching up with you guys.
right? Like they're um usually if you
see everybody sprinting to do the same
thing, that's a great indication that
it's the wrong thing. Um and so so like
as or or like a thing that eventually
the model will will have that capability
to do. Um so so one of my favorite
examples of this is that um you know
when the models were first released they
had context windows of like 8,000 tokens
16,000 tokens and so everybody was
sprinting to build a vector database um
because they were like oh well we have
to work around this constraint that the
models have this very small context
window um and then you know obviously
that's expanded over time. Um there's
another great uh example of you know
everybody sprinting to build fine-tunes
of models to support different
languages. Um though now models support
a variety of languages. If you've been
uh kind of listening along for some of
the Google DeepMind sessions today,
you've seen that in action. And then
also many of our competitor models also
support multiple languages. And so I
think like we we also saw everybody
sprinting to build an agent framework
when the reality is I think that the m
like all of that will probably be
absorbed into the model eventually. Um
and also everybody sprinting towards
things like building MCP servers whereas
now mostly people have kind of moved
away from MCP servers and are adopting
skills which are just fancy markdown
files. Um, and then obviously longer
term you could imagine like, oh hey, I
just want a little listener um, watching
everything that I do and it will
automatically create skills behind the
scenes for me to use. And we're
starting. Yep. Yep.
>> I was going to say I do not necessarily
agree because you guys will always cater
the most applications but very very
specific ones like for instance which is
where I'm working Google is not going to
work on that. So those kind of
>> so so counter counter example um our
first implementation of Palm 2 and our
first implementation of Gemini we had to
have a fine-tune one called MedLM and
one called MedPalM to support medical
use cases. Um, now we see that all of
the people who had previously needed to
rely on those fine-tunes are just using
Gemini out of the box with either
retrieval or with a custom prompt
because all of the data that we used for
those fine tunes is just incorporated
into Gemini itself.
>> But you have the issue of
reproducibility. You're not going to
have the same results. You're going to
have a lot of
consequence.
>> So so no large language model is
deterministic. Um so so that will be a
problem regardless. Um but I but I do
agree like there there are um you know I
think a lot of the magic is going to
come from having like a very opinionated
view of use cases um and being able to
work directly with customers and solve
their problems. Um so with that and
that's a perfect segue into uh into the
session today. So greetings everyone.
Thank you for being brave and for coming
back. Um I know that there were a lot of
people who were uh unable to to join us
earlier this morning um for some of the
sessions that we had. Um so just show of
hands how many folks came back this
afternoon were not here this morning or
uh like were uh cool cool. Excellent. So
uh we have a treat for you today. Um for
the sessions that we delivered earlier
um we're going to do basically a recap
of them. So, we'll be walking through
all of the all of the examples. Um, you
won't have uh you won't uh uh kind of
walk away feeling like you've missed
anything. Um, and uh I'll be doing some
within AI Studio and anti-gravity. Um,
and then my colleague uh my colleague
Gom and you can also see one of my
agents that's kind of doing its thing
with computer use and browsing. Um uh
the uh I'm going to disconnect for a
second so we don't accidentally see
something that perhaps should not be
shared. Um and then uh going to go
straight into slideshow view.
Awesome. So uh greetings everyone. My
name is Paige. Um so I I am really
excited to be here today. Um, and I am
especially excited to show you all of
the things that we've been doing at
Google Deep Mind over the course of the
last year, um, last, uh, six months. Uh,
it's been a wild ride and never in my
career have I been more excited to be a
machine learning engineer working in
this space. Um, just over the last month
and a half, uh, it feels a little bit
like whiplash. Um, we've released a ton
of different things. Um, so Gemini 3.1
Flash Live, um, which we'll take a look
at in a second, uh, which gives you the
ability to have a real-time conversation
with the model. Um, Gemini 3.1 Pro and
Flash Light, um, respectively, our
largest and our very, very small but
very capable model. Um, that are also
very coste effective, very performant.
Um, Augment Code, if you've heard of
them, they're a company over in the Bay
Area. They've just recently replatted
their entire agent infrastructure to
default to Gemini 3.1 Pro specifically
because of performance and cost ratios.
Um it can do a lot of really good work
in a very like um small number of
pennies. Uh also Nano Banana 2 for image
generation, image editing, including
reverse image search, which we'll also
take a look at in a second. Um and
you'll be hearing about from my
colleague Guom, who's our expert in
generative media. um our embedded 2.0
model which allows you to embed video,
audio, images, code, and text in the
same embedding space. Um so you can say
like show me everything you have related
to llamas and you will see everything
from um like stuffed llamas to pictures
of llamas to videos of llamas to things
of like what does it sound like when a
llama makes noises cuz I don't know but
like the model the model somehow does.
Um, LIA 3 for music generation, Genie3
for world model building, um, our full
stack runtime with AI studio which
allows you to incorporate database OOTH.
Um, a custom API keys if you want to use
other services and a whole bunch of
other things. GIMA 4 for open models.
Um, we just released it last week under
an Apache 2 license which is really
exciting if you care about open models.
And then also VO3.1 light for video
generation. Um so massive number of
things across a broad spectrum of
surfaces. Um and part of the reason for
this is because Gemini is kind of unique
in the industry in a couple of ways. One
of which is that it's natively
multimodal. So it can understand video
and images and audio and text and code
and all of the above all at once. Um but
it can also output multiple modalities.
So it can output text, it can output
code just like all of the other
competitors on the market. Um, but it
can also output images, it can edit
images, it can output images and text
interleved and it can also output audio
tokens. Um, so uh, so pretty pretty
compelling use cases. Um, but I think
it's a lot more interesting to see it
rather than to just have me waxing
poetic about it. Um, and for that I am
going to go into AI studio real quick.
Um, and we're going to take a look at
some of the things that Gemini can do.
Um, so first off, how many people have
used AI Studio before? Um, excellent.
I'm very very glad that all of the Deep
Minders have raised their hands. Um,
but, uh, for folks who have not, uh, AI
Studio is kind of the best place to go
to get access to DeepMind's models as
soon as they're released. Um, we have a
playground feature. We also have a build
feature, which we'll see in a second,
which is very similar to vzero.dev or
lovable. Um, you can select different
models here off to the right. Um so you
can see if I click on the model name um
we see some pills um everything from
Gemini to live capabilities um image uh
image uh generation video generation
audio generation and music um and then
also our Gemma open model family which
we'll also take a look at in a second.
Um you can select different models for
the purposes of speed I am selecting
Gemini 3.1 flashlight preview. I am also
on my personal instance of AI Studio and
this is an attempt to drive down costs.
Um so Gemini uh 3.1 flashlight is around
25 cents per million tokens analyzed. Um
which is really really good. Uh almost
an order of magnitude lower than our
Gemini 3.1 Pro model. Um and it can
still analyze video, audio, etc. um uh
it's just uh a lot more lightweight,
which means that you might not always
get the the same great capabilities. Um
but it usually does a pretty good job.
Um and you can do everything from
analyzing images to analyzing video. So
if I as an example um was going to look
up a was going to look like a dinosaur
YouTube video. Um we already used this
Rexy the the little T-Rex before. Um so
I know it works. Um but uh but I am
going to find um maybe this one uh
carnado uh which is
>> uh which is it looks like a very very
long video so around an hour long. Um we
might uh chop it up a little bit. But if
you click this plus sign you can see
that you can add different files. So you
can either add files from drive
everything from text files to um uh to
PDFs. Um, you can upload files directly.
You can record audio live. Um, add
camera footage. Add a link to a YouTube
video, which we'll do right now. Um, so
I paste in the link to the YouTube
video. I'll do a start time of 0 seconds
and an end time of around 300. Um, and
it samples at around one frame per
second. Um, and then what you see is
this is, you know, 30,000
um, uh, 30,900
tokens. I'm going to make sure to turn
on Google search grounding off to the
right. And I'm going to say, please
create a table with timestamps for all
of the kinds of dinosaurs that you see
in this video. Um, make sure to include
a fun fact about each dinosaur. Um, for
all of the other dinosaur experts, um,
like armchair dinosaur experts in the in
the room, you might have noticed that it
said Carnonosaurus. I am skeptical that
that's an actual dinosaur. Um, so, uh,
we'll see. We'll see what happens. Um,
but what's, uh, going on behind the
scenes is that the model is getting sent
this YouTube video for inference. And
it's not just the metadata associated
with the YouTube video, it's also frame
by frame um the video itself. And a
question
>> um like uh does anyone else have uh does
anyone else have issues with seeing the
settings or like uh could we could we
change the lighting? Oh, is this better?
>> Oh, excellent. Awesome. Um, so so that's
uh thank you for thank you for the
request. Like it's I I did I can see it
perfectly on my screen. Usually my eyes
get a little irritated by light mode,
but this is um as long as it's better.
And so um so it took in the video. Um it
defined the different dinosaurs that it
sees. Um it says that the name means
mediating bull. Um mentioned
triceratops.
Um, and then also mentioned that
pyranodons are not necessarily
dinosaurs. They're a group of flying
reptiles. Um, and then if I wanted to uh
if I wanted to get the code that was
used to generate this experience um and
I wanted to replicate it in my own app,
all I have to do is click get code and
it automatically configures the model.
Um it configures the uh the URL that I
have inputed um the kind of the offset
for the video the the prompt that I used
um and it's in Typescript, Python or
whatever your favorite language might
be. So the TLDDR is that if you can get
it working in AI Studio, you can get it
working as part of your app. All you
have to do is click the get code button.
Um
so that is a Gemini 3.1 flashlight for
analyzing video. Um, you can also use it
to analyze images with a couple of other
bakedin tools. Um, and if we look over
to the right, we can see structured
outputs, code execution, things like
function calling, even for custom
functions. Um, also some things like URL
context. Um, and all of these are very
very special, but they're also just
oneliners if you want to use them as
part of your API. Um, so as an example,
if I turn on code execution,
um, I'm going to see a Gemini 3.1
flashlight selected, um, I'm going to go
into compare mode. So I want to compare
it, um, with maybe the Gemini 3 flash
preview, also with code execution turned
on. Um, and I'm going to look for a
picture of Lego bricks.
Um, this one.
And copy the image.
Uh, and right now we're in compare mode.
So I'm comparing two different models,
both with the same tool turned on. Um,
and say something to the effect of draw
bounding boxes
around all of the green Lego bricks uh
using Python. Um, make sure uh or
display the image
with bounding boxes.
And code execution is sort of giving
Gemini the ability to uh to sort of
stand up a makeshift Python environment
that's sandboxed um use a whole bunch of
data science libraries that are
pre-installed um and use those invoke
them as tool calls um kind of like
writing the code and incorporating
anything that you might share in. So, I
shared in um this image uh and very very
quickly, I'm not sure if you saw how
quickly um but it was able to draw
bounding boxes around the the green Lego
bricks, you could also ask for
segmentation masks. Um and even more
excitingly, so Gemini 3 Flash is still
plugging along. Um, but if you look at
how much this cost um to do to define
the bounding boxes, you could have also
asked for things like um tell me how
many green Legos there are or tell me uh
um you know what are the orientations of
the Lego bricks. Tell me uh how many uh
you know what are they called? The
little funny rabbit things, laboo. Tell
me how many of those you see in all of
the frames of this video. um and at what
time stamp like those those are the
kinds of tools that can be invoked um
via the sandbox environment. Um and
again like very very inexpensive in
order to do this work with Gemini 3.1
flashlight and code execution turned on.
Um and it's just a oneliner to stand up
that sandbox Python environment um with
compute that Gemini can use to do that
work.
Cool.
And it looks like the uh it looks like
the Gemini 3 flash preview was able to
do it. It was checking its work. So that
was the iteration that it was going
through along the way. So it got this
first result and it said, "All right, I
want to double check and verify that
what I did was right. It drew the
segmentation mask with uh to like define
all of the the like green spectrums um
that it saw in the image. Uh and then it
kind of verified that those were the
correct coordinates. Um and still if I
look um it's significantly more cost
with the verification but still on the
order of pennies in order to draw the
bounding boxes. It just took a little
bit more time and also a lot more tool
calls to invoke. Um so I strongly
strongly recommend um playing around
with Gemini 3.1 flashlight for your use
cases especially if previously you were
relying on Gemini 2.0 flash or 2.5
flash.
Cool. Um, so we also have a feature
called build. Um, build again is kind of
similar to v0ero.dev or uh or lovable if
you've played with that before. Um, uh,
we've recently added a feature where you
can add database and off to your apps
within build. Um, and so as an example
today, if I wanted to click this guy,
um, and say something to the effect of
um, create an app that gives the user
the ability to upload an image of their
bookshelf. Um, the bookshelf should have
a whole bunch of books on it with uh, so
we can see their spines. Um, uh, things
like titles and author names. Um, I want
you to use Google search grounding to uh
to fill in the blanks uh for for the
books. Um, so make sure that you have
information about the title, um, the
author name, the description of the
book, and then also what kind of genre
uh, it might be. Um, and I want you to
save it all to a database. Um, so the
user logs in with uh with their Google
account. Um, they upload a picture of uh
of their bookshelf. Um, and it saves all
of their books uh in like this database
format. Um, so they know what books they
have and it's attached to their account
which is a tall ask. Um, so so it's uh
kind of defined that work. I'm going to
I've got 3.1 Pro Preview selected. I'm
going to do the default instead in the
hopes that it might be a little bit
faster. Um, and I'm going to click
build. And what happens behind the
scenes is we get um we get put into this
IDE like environment um where you can
see the the model kind of going through
the thinking process figuring out what
it would need to do in order to spec out
the assignment um build the plan how
long it's working. Um you can also
upload files. So you can upload uh files
that you might have like PDFs or specs
for apps that you would like to create
um and give them to the model as well.
you can connect to your drive instance.
Um, and we also have a settings section
off to the right where you can define
custom secrets. So, right now I have a
Gemini API key that I've pre uh
pre-added. Um, but you could also add
like a Superbase API key or um an API
key for NADEN or whatever your favorite
flavor might be. Um, you can see a new
version history which if you've played
with AI Studio before is definitely uh
something that is much appreciated. Um,
and then also integrations. So things
like OOTH, um, as well as GitHub, so you
can sync to a public or a private
repository. Um, but while this is
working, um, I'm going to go ahead and
show off, uh, something called, uh,
Genie 3. Um, or actually before that,
I'm going to show off Gemini Live real
quick. Um, just in case folks haven't
seen it. Um, so how many people have
heard of Gemini Live? Few hands. Cool,
cool, cool. Um, uh, we also happen to
have the expert for Gemini Live. Uh,
Ian, come on down. Uh, Ian is the, uh,
the Gemma the Gemma 4, uh, team member
that I had mentioned, uh, that I had
mentioned before, and he'll be doing
some live model demos, which makes me
really excited. Um,
but, uh, Gemini live gives you the
ability to have a conversation with the
model in a variety of languages. Um, but
you can also share video feeds, you can
share your screen. Um, and all of this
is kind of stacked together in one
speechtoext LLM understanding and
texttospech pipeline. Um, so as an
example, um, uh, we've still got our
Lego bricks and pieces pulled up so I
can share my screen to say,
uh, hey there Gemini. Uh, what do you
see on the screen?
I see a Google search for Lego bricks
and pieces. There are image results
showing various kinds of Lego pieces,
sets, and different color combinations.
On the right, there's a larger preview
of some brightly colored Lego brick
illustrations from Freepick. Anything
specific you're looking for? Does
anybody speak a language other than
English?
>> Seek.
>> See? Oh, excellent. So, so I'm going to
I'm going to ask for you to factcheck
something. Um, and also spellch checkck
something. Um, so only respond to the
user in seek. Is that correct?
>> I meant Spanish.
>> Oh, sorry. The Oh, gotcha. So, Spanish
and Yep. Oh, there we go. Uh, only uh
Spanish. Excellent. Um, and then I was
about to say I don't know that language
or I haven't had that before. Um, but
only response
>> Spanish.
>> I know I know Spanish. Like I grew up in
Texas, so it's kind of like prerequisite
to know Spanish. Uh but the uh but I'm
going to share again. Um
hey Gemini, could you tell me what you
see on the screen?
Or hopefully
let me see. No, I don't think
to click the microphone again.
>> Oh, it's the There you go. Like the uh
So, one of the things one of the things
that you can do so you see that I've
modified the system instructions.
Um but uh like do you speak a specific
dialect of Spanish?
Castellian Spanish. Okay,
>> excellent. So, um I removed the system
instructions and I should be able to do
this just within the span of
conversation. Um so,
hey Gemini, could you tell me what you
see on the screen, but could you do it
in Castellian Spanish?
Excellent.
>> Yep. Awesome. So, so you can uh you can
ask within the span of the conversation.
You can um modify the system
instructions to select different
languages or different dialects. Um, and
then again the same thing if you click
get code, um, it gives you the code that
you would need to use to replicate
whatever you just did. Um, so the model
name, any configuration settings, um, as
well as any tool calls that you might
invoke. Um, and it works with sharing
your screen. Um, you can kind of
interact with your screen as you share
it. Um, but it also works with video
feeds. So you can say um
hey Gemini, how many fingers am I
holding up? And also compose a poem
about me.
Well, I see two fingers up like the
peace sign. And here's a little poem for
you. With golden hair and an open heart,
you come to learn, to play your part.
The cameras focus, moments start, a
creative spirit, a work of art. How was
that? That was very sweet. Thank you.
The And so the uh the models are able to
to kind of interact uh to view video
feeds to to view the the screens. Um and
you can stitch them together in your own
projects. Um just taking a look. I'm
going to enable Firebase real quick. Um
so it should be setting up the database
for that app that we were building. And
then the other thing that I wanted to
show is something called Genie. Um, so
if you haven't heard of Genie before,
this is a world model that DeepMind has
created. Um, it's actually a composition
of models. Um, so Nano Banana, VO, a
bunch of Gemini used for prompting. Um,
and it's stitched together into a system
that allows you to describe something um
like a a game, an environment with a
character um that you can interact with
that you can uh play this game uh and
and sort of do it pixel by pixel. So it
doesn't generate a Unity environment. It
doesn't generate an environment for
Unreal Engine. Um it just generates this
uh kind of frame by frame experience um
for anything that you can imagine. And
co. So it could look something like this
volcanic landscape where you're
navigating with a little rover um with
your arrow keys. Um or something like
this jet ski where like you hit a light
um and it feels like the physics is
happening or like the physics is uh like
responding in a real way. Um if you
knocked that light into the water and
then circled back around, it would
persist throughout the duration of your
60-second experiment. Um but there's no
physics engine behind the scenes. Um,
and then even things like experiencing a
hurricane in Florida, you can start with
a static image or like a family photo.
Um, and see how uh see how some of these
things get created. Um, but for this, I
am going to go back to my other browser.
Um, I'm going to pull up Project Genie.
I'm going to click explore now.
Then I'm going to say something like uh
a world. Um maybe a Regent's Canal on a
sunny um day. Um but with dolphins
uh swimming
in the canal
and uh all of the boats have pirate
flags, um which is hopefully not part of
the training data. And then uh the the
uh sort of character description would
be um you know something again kind of
atypical maybe a pink sparkly squirrel
um uh with
um a pink sparkly squirrel with a purple
um purple feet and
um
a pirate hat.
uh and then create the sketch. And what
should happen is that it uses Nano
Banana to to kind of ideate on that
first frame. It'll show it to us to to
make sure that it looks consistent with
what we had described. Um uh clearly
like Regent's Canal is getting overtaken
by pink sparkly squirrels with pirate
hats. Um, and then what uh what we
should see is kind of this first
iteration and then a playable world that
we can interact with for just 60
seconds, at least for the um at least
for the first implementation that we've
released to the public. You're able to
access Genie 3 through an ultra
subscription in some parts of the world.
um not every part um but uh but
hopefully hopefully I haven't over
booked my uh my GPU or TPU aotment or
allocation
um if we have uh we can take a look back
at the um we can take a look back at
shelf scan. It looks like the model is
doing the work of creating the creating
the fire store rules for us. Oh, there
we go. So, pink sparkly squirrel, um,
pirate hat, regions canal, dolphins.
That looks pretty good. Um, so let's go
ahead and create this world. Um, you can
use the arrow keys to move around the,
uh, or the WD keys to move around and
then the arrow keys to change the
perspective. Um, and then we should also
be able to use the space bar to jump.
Um, but let's see. Let's see how this
works.
Uh, oh gosh. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. squirrel.
Um, and so it looks like it's walking on
water, the squirrel. Um, or like uh
hopping along. Um, you can also jump.
Um, so jump on top of the boats. Uh, you
can see the the little bicycles. Um, you
can see some of the people along the
way. Um, and it does look like all of
these boats on Regent's Canal um have uh
have pirate flags uh and dolphins um
that are not currently moving, which is
which is pretty wild. Um, and then if I
click uh spacebar, you can see the
squirrel jump. Um, it looks like it
doesn't realize that Regent's Canal has
pretty deep water, so I probably should
have specified that in my prompt. Um,
and then you can also see it uh attempt
to jump. um uh attempt to jump into the
uh onto the sidewalk uh and do do its
work. Um so it's wild to be able to see
the things that you can create. Um the
different uh the different experiences
that you can construct. Um and again,
it's even more bonkers to me um that
each part of this is being generated
dynamically um as you're moving your
arrow keys around. Um so it creates a
video at the very end that you can
download that you can uh kind of see and
review and interact with. Um and uh this
is again just using Gen3 and this
composition of models as opposed to a
singular model. Um other world model
building companies so things like World
Labs um that's Fe Lee's company are
taking a slightly different approach.
They're they're building out actual
Unity environments or Unreal Engine
environments. Um, none of these things
are stored as 3D game assets. Um,
they're just kind of like raw pixels um
that are incorporated into the into the
experience.
Cool. So, going back to AI Studio, it
looks like the app is still getting uh
the app is still getting cooked. Um, let
me uh and hopefully hopefully we'll be
able to see it. Usually, whenever it
starts working on config files, that
means that it's almost done. Um, I also
really love looking through it to see um
like what its approach towards the the
construction of the fire store rules
were. Um, what its approach towards
prompting the model might be. Um, it
looks like it's confirming the app. Um,
and then uh once it's done, it should
make a little bitty noise um to uh to
talk through um to talk through the the
app itself. Um, so it looks like it's
ask asking to allow my camera. Um, so
I'm going to allow.
Um, we have this shelf scan AI
experience. I'm going to sign in with
Google
with my personal account. We can see
that it's connected to Fire Store. Um,
I'm going to find very quickly a
bookshelf um with books on it.
Let's see.
Those don't look like real books because
many of them are hanging like suspended
uh below the shelf. Um like AI AI image
generation makes it hard. But this is uh
this one looks decent. So like let's
save this image. Um looks like somebody
has a whole bunch of cooking books. Uh
I'm going to upload the photo. So this
pixel photo um and hope that it can
understand uh hope that it can
understand web pages orwp
um rather format. Um it's gathering data
via Google search. Um and then the books
should be populated in the library
hopefully. If not we can try with a
JPEG.
But it does have pretty good branding.
Um, it was able to identify the seven
books it looks like. Um, or at least
like it identified the books. Let me try
uh let me try again but just with a JPEG
image. Um, so I'm going to just take a
screenshot. So same image just stored as
a screenshot.
I'll find
in here. So, desktop screenshot
at 417.
Then identify books.
And if not, we can try fixing the errors
as well um to see what might have been
going wrong.
Oh, so so it looks like the uh there are
insufficient permissions
um for saving in fire store. Um so uh so
it looks like it's going ahead and
fixing fixing those issues. Um but as it
does um you can also see that you can
log in, you can log out, you can share
the app. Um so you can specify who has
access to it, share full screen. Um and
one of the things that I also really
really love about AI Studio um is that
uh it's figuring out uh where the files
should be modified in order to make
those changes. Um so it's figuring out
the validation logic. It's figuring out
that the that the size um might have
been the corporate um so the the image
URL size um and then it's figuring out
where it would need to modify in order
to uh in order to make that change. Um
so it looks like it's in the fire store
rules. Um some of the other nice things
about AI Studios build feature is that
we have um an app gallery. So if you
need to get inspired for some of the
apps uh that are using our models, you
can kind of review them. Everything from
LIA for music generation to um
multiplayer experiences with games. So
you can see this multiplayer neon snake
or this mandal bulb explorer. Um you can
see a design with nano banana. So like
being able to change and modify images.
Um, you can take a look at the sik uh
media pipe example. Um, which allows you
to to kind of play this game where your
hand is detected. Um, but you take this
little uh and everybody can find out
that I play this game really poorly. Um,
uh, how to uh, uh, move one of the
little one of the little marble deals.
Um,
oh gosh, I am really horrible at this
game. Um, but the uh and then it also
sounds like the other app uh finished
getting created. Um, perfect timing. Um,
but if I if I sort of upload the image,
let's try to identify the book again.
Fingers crossed.
Yep. And then it automatically populates
all of the books. So they all got uh
they got all got cataloged with the
date, the the type of book, the details
associated, um the name of the book, the
author, even though some of those were
not uh available in the in the spines of
the books that I uploaded. Um, if I log
out and then log back in, um,
it keeps all of the the books that I had
added persisted. Um, and if I wanted to
share this with all of you because
clearly I want to know what all of y'all
have on your bookshelves. Um, I could
copy this link and then do a QR code
generator.
Um,
and uh, if you use this QR code, you
should be able to access the app that I
just created, upload your own bookshelf
images, and then have them cataloged um,
to your own uh, to your own apps. Um,
next feature would be like finding a way
to give my friends the ability to
request them. Um because every time I
give my friends a book um they they have
a tendency to keep it which I understand
but is also like exhausting. I have so
many copies of Infinite Jest out in the
world. Um but the uh but this is the um
like uh just kind of a whirlwind tour of
some of the things that you can do in AI
studio some of the new features that
we've added the new models that we have
available. Um and with that I am going
to welcome my colleague Guiam um who is
going to tell you all about our
generative media models. So everything
from music generation to image creation,
image editing to video generation. Um
and it should be a fun time. Um so thank
you so much. Thank you for coming.
Hello everybody.
You will need the up
and this is the right one.
>> You're going to be awesome. And then do
I have where did I leave?
>> You can you can show my screen now.
Okay, good. Um, so as as P said, we are
it's going to be the same talk as I did
this morning, the same workshop. Uh, we
have slightly less time. So I'm going to
go faster on some things and maybe not
run things uh in real time. But you like
the the content I'm going to show is on
this uh this link. So if you just you
can you can just open it and and run it
yourself at the same time. Um,
so uh I'm going to talk about generative
media. Um generative media is everything
about creating um images, videos uh
text uh um like spoken text and uh and
things like that. I think I would I
would fit Jenny into gen media as well.
Um so yeah and we have plenty of models
like that at deep mind. So let me let me
go through all of them. Um so very
quickly my name is Guom. Uh I've been at
Google for six years now. Two years at
Divine doing uh developer advocacy. Uh
mainly most on most of the Gemini model
until last year and since and this year
I'm focusing more on the on the gen
media models because that's the funniest
model to play with. Um I've been I've
been working in the video game industry
before. Um and that's how I joined
Google initially.
So uh yeah, open your phones. Everything
is a media. I already said that.
Basically, um Paige talked a bit about
our vision of what um world models are.
My definition of a world model is
something that can uh ingest as many
modalities as as it as it can and
understand them kind of for five senses
and to to also talk or output things in
different modalities as well. So that
really has been at the core of the deep
mind vision of what uh generative AI
should be. Uh the the first gen Gemini
model like it was only two years ago but
it seems old but it was only a text to
text uh to textto text model but
actually behind the scenes it was
already a multimodel model because and
that and you could have been sending it
images but it was blocked. They did for
testing reasons. I don't I don't
remember why but basically they blocked
it in the model with with post training
and then when it released a few months
afterwards we released 1.5. This one the
new the novelty was that it was uh the
first multimodel model. Uh sometimes
when you were giving it a picture it was
it was answering I'm sorry I'm just LLM.
I can't do anything with images because
some of the that training was still
still in there. Um but basically yes we
we want to create those models that can
understand all of the physics of the
world from videos audios and and all of
that. Uh and the only reason why we have
so many different models is that it's
easier to ship one models that only does
video and one models that only does
images and one models that only text
than to have like one models that does
everything. And then it it becames a
problem. every time we want to update
one of the feature we have to release a
whole new model and everybody has to to
convert and all. So that's that's just
the reason for that. Um
everybody knows us for the Gemini models
we have lots of other models I will go
over like I will skip that for now. Um
quick um quick timeline. Uh we release
things all the time. Uh I think Paige
says it said it earlier on on average we
are releasing a new model or new
capabilities every five days. Uh that's
just the gen media models. Uh there's
all of the other models on top of that.
And if you add all of the changes we are
doing in AI studio, all of the pricing
things like small features here and
there we are releasing like two to three
new new things every week. Um
and um so yeah, it's so it's basically
it's it's hard to keep track and like
it's even hard for us to keep track of
everything we have to offer. So I know
that's that for people like uh like you
it's even harder because you also have
to look at what the the competition is
doing. Um so that's also why we are
doing those those um those talks very
quickly. uh the the updates on Nano
Banana. We released Nano Banana 2 a few
months ago um in
end of January, the beginning of
February. Uh the main thing is that you
can output different uh as aspect ratio
and u sizes. Um it has search grounding.
So that's basically how I do you don't
see my screen anymore.
Why?
Okay, just imagine in your head that's
that's what media ads are for. Um, so
the the main thing about Oh, thank you.
Nano Banana uh Pro was that it it add
search grounding. So you could ask it to
search for the internet and that's how I
made this image. Like just look for what
you can find about my footprint on
Google and make an image about me which
is kind of scary in a way. Um
and but the new things with Neo Banana 2
is that you can do the same thing with
image running. So it can you can uh talk
about a specific places a specific like
bridge like that and it will look for
for an image on on the web and then
create image based on that. So that's
without running and that's without
grounding. So you can see that it's
looks a bit more than the uh than the
normal building.
We also have VO. Very quickly on VO the
main novelty in the past uh week is that
we released V 3.1 light last week uh
which is the cheapest model for
generating video we have. So it's only 5
cent per per image. So it's which is way
way cheaper than what V3 was a year ago.
So the idea that you can use that to
prototype, test your prompts and so on.
And then if you want better quality then
you can move to the to the better
models.
Uh and then LA 3 is the the the coolest
model this year. Uh it's all music
generation model. Uh so you can either
generate uh 30 seconds songs or full
songs of three minutes uh with the
lyrics and all of that. And I will I
will show you some demos afterwards. Um
and I've as far as I know we are the
first one to offer such uh music
generation models through API. So that's
really cool for any kind of uh agentic
or whatever workflow you you might have.
So if you want to be waken up with a
song about the latest news every
morning, you can do it.
Um, and also another one very quickly
that I love but nobody knows about is
that we have actually another LIA model
that is LA real time and this one is
basically a live model. So it's creating
music uh indefinitely and and you can
just prompt it differently. So it's just
going to change what you are uh the kind
of music it's generating in real real
time like a DJ. So, it's it's pretty fun
to play with, but uh some old like
people don't know about it. Um as I
said, I'm going to because it's it's
meant to be a workshop. So, the idea is
that you test things yourself. Uh so,
you can open this uh this link and that
will show you the the content I
prepared. Um while you take pictures and
all uh just one disclaimer, it's gen
media models. So, they are all paid
models. So they like running the
notebook actually costs a bit of money.
Um
the video the the the video generation
is going to be the most expensive thing.
So you can just keep that. Uh the rest
is pretty cheap. So I think you can run
the wall the wall notebook for something
like one one. So it should be should be
fine. But just I prefer to to be uh to
be clear with everybody.
So let's let's move to it.
So
what's the idea of this workshop? So the
the idea was to showcase all of the gen
media models with this uh this example
of we're going to take a book uh and I'm
going we are going to take a book from
an an open-source library. So uh we are
allowed to use it and then we are going
to create images to illustrate uh what
the characters look like what the and
what's happening in each chapter and
then we are going to move to the other
gen media models. So creating videos uh
about uh about the chapter and then
creating music and having Gemini uh tell
us about uh what's happening in the in
the chapter. So this is just setup. You
need to install the SDK. You need an API
key. I guess you can you could have
guessed that. Uh I'm initializing the
client. And something that uh I didn't
know about until recently is that you
actually have a way when initializing
the client to uh implement some retry
system. So which is kind of uh very
useful uh nowadays with whenever you use
nano banana too because uh especially
when the US wakes up it's becoming
harder to uh to get to uh to get
something out of it. uh and we're
working all of yeah we're working on
getting more capacity but still uh it's
having some kind of retry system al
always helps
um so import and then we are selecting
the models and I usually when when I
create content for that are using paid
models I usually have some kind of
checkbox that uh you can if you if
you're opening it's already checked it
should be it should not be but I made a
mistake yesterday evening uh because I
don't want people to run the models and
have to pay uh especially the the VO the
VO notebook for example example like
cost something like $20 to run so I
don't want anybody to run it by mistake
um just for the sake of the of the demo
I'm also limiting the number of
characters images and chapters images we
are creating just so that it's it's
faster to run and all so the book is uh
named the wind of the willows from
Kenneth Graham and I'm I took it from
the project Gutenberg libraries which is
an open-source library where you can
download open source books. For some
reason it doesn't work uh since I've
been in the UK. So there has to be
something about this library not being
available in the UK. Um but if you run
the notebook it should work because it's
very likely the server is in in another
country. So it will be able to recover
the book. Um so so what I'm doing is
that I'm just downloading this uh this
book here like I like with a with a get
uh URL and um I didn't say I didn't talk
about that and page neither. So uh very
quickly uh because everybody's always
asking that question to us. We have a
specialty at Google is that we are
always creating multiple projects that
are doing the same thing multiple
products and we are doing we did the
same with messaging apps. We are doing
the same with uh with Gemini. So that's
can that can be a bit confusing. So just
very quickly to uh to clarify things
um so if you if you look at the graph
like basically we have the consumers
apps. So on the on the on the left it's
the apps that are for everybody. You can
do plenty of things with them. You can
uh you can ask any question to Gemini.
you can generate the images and all but
as a developer like I guess everybody in
the room you can be kind of frustrated
because you don't uh you can't really
access the parameters select the exact
model that is doing you can't it you
know that it's it's likely doing cool
tool cool cool tool calls but you don't
know which one it's doing so that's uh
that's nice for the for the broad public
but it's uh it's not really for us um on
the other end we have Vertex AI which is
our enterprise ized uh offer that's the
exact opposite. You have a lot of
control. You can decide in which data
center your your prompts are going to be
run. So especially in Europe, a lot of
people are looking to be certain that
that the data is not going to to leave
Europe. So that's um that's kind of
convenient for that. But it comes with
uh like great responsibilities as well.
So it's kind of hard to set up. So I
usually only recommend people to start
with Vert.Ex text if they are already
using GCP or if they have a team of
devops who can do the setup for them and
and in the middle ground we have AI
studio and the developer APIs that we
made for developers but basically the
idea that it's as easy as possible to
start to play with the model and and do
stuff by just creating an API key and
then using it um and as part
as easy as possible
uh Yeah, as part as easy as possible, we
have this uh client file upload API that
is basically a way to not have to set up
buckets to store your your files. And uh
we are going to I'm using it in this
example so that we are uploading it to
this behind the scenes. It's creating a
bucket, but you just the idea is that
you don't have to bother with how it
works. You just upload the file and then
you can use it in your in your Gemini
prompts afterwards.
Um, I'm also going to use uh structured
outputs because I want to be certain
about what exactly the model is going to
to do because I I'm going to have it uh
to to ask it uh to generate a lot of
prompts. So I want to know exactly that
uh it's just returning the prompt and
not some like uh introduction or um text
or something like like the oh yes sure I
can do that and then you it's hard to
pass. So that's why we are I'm having
this uh this structured output and I'm
using chat mode which is basically a way
to uh u to chain request to uh to the
model so that you can uh it's it
basically saves the history and resend
history so that the models knows what
happens before which is quite convenient
in this case because we don't want to
upload the book all the time. We just
want to the the book to be in the
history and in the in the context so the
models can ask uh can answer new
questions and generate new prompts about
the book. And for the images, it's going
to be quite the same by by using this
system. We will have all the previous
images that are going to be in memory.
So the model will be better at uh
keeping the consistency of the
characters and better and the
consistency of the style.
So uh I'm just giving it the book.
Here's the booku to illustrate with nano
banana. That's all. Then I'm defining a
style. So I went I I made it so that you
can just do nothing and the the model
will come up with the style. But then I
wanted to try something else earlier. So
it's going to be a dark fantasy style
with black and white background and
colored characters. Um, and basically I
also adding some system instructions for
for Nano Banana because I uh from my
earlier test I think it's better with
Nano Banana 2 and Pro. But with the
first Nano Banana um whenever I was
asking it images about books that were
in the portrait um format, it it tend to
to book covers that I wanted. So it it
was always adding titles and things like
that. So I had to add some system
instructions to make sure that I I don't
want borders. I don't want titles. I
don't want description. I stay family
friendly which is likely to not be very
aligned with dark fantasy I guess. Um
and uh and no panels as well because I
don't want uh I don't want a comic book.
I want just an image for for each
chapter. And then basically I will use
that chat to ask the model to describe
each of the main characters. Uh I
initially wrote only the adults but
because at some points Nano Banana could
not generate uh kids images in Europe
but that's not the case anymore. So we
could remove that part
and I I'm getting this this list of
characters and a prompt for each of
them. And then I can just go over uh
each of the each of the prompts and ask
Nano Banana to create an image that to
illustrate that um that that prompt. So
that's how I initial I initialize the
image chart. So it's going to be a
separate chart. Um and then I'm sending
all of the all of the uh the prompts to
create to to be created. So we can see
that uh
so that's that's small the main
character. So, uh, as as requested, the
background is black and white, and the
character has colored. Um, not very dark
fantasy, but yeah. Um, that's uh the
water rat.
That's the toad.
Uh, the the badger. The Yeah, the
badger.
And, uh, that's that's it for now. And
then I'm going to do the same thing
again like uh now you you have the full
book in your in your history. So give me
prompts for each chapter to illustrate
them. So up I get a prompt for each of
those uh chapter and I'm creating images
for for each of the prompt.
So here we have the the characters
having a picnic next to the river. Then
another one's on the road and
something's happening. Um, and here in
the forest, that's that's the first
chapter. And if you look closely, you
can see that there's there was a problem
here because the toad was not uh
represented using the uh the character
uh the the images that we we created
before. Um likely because the prompt was
not clear that it was exactly the same
character. Um and so which is why I I
have a second way of doing it which is
actually cleaner. And if you were to do
that to do that at scale, that's that's
how I would do it. Um, and in I'm
creating another type of structured
output which is which is a chapter which
is which has a name and the prompt as
well, but also list of characters that
that are meant to appear in the in the
image. And so I'm I'm running I'm asking
again the model to to come up with
something, but this time is it's giving
me the list of the character. And that
way I can um basically here um for each
for each image that I'm going to create
also give the reference images of what
the character should be looking like. So
that's it only has that those images in
in its context instead of having all of
the possible images that we did before.
In this case we have something like five
five characters. So it's okay. But if
you are in a real book with like 40
characters, that that wouldn't be
sustainable to uh to expect the models
to actually manage all of the all of the
context perfectly. Um and and and
honestly, if I was to to do it at scale,
I think I would even create more than
one image for each character. Maybe one
one image from the front, one from the
back, one from each side. So that and
and then I would pass exactly the one
that I that I need in the in this case.
So we can see that the image are looks
kind of the same but uh this time the
the toad is the right one.
Uh yeah this one really look like
um so now we can move uh to the next
step and we can use VO to create like
small videos based on those images. So
I'm I'm using the the VO the largest
model because it's uh because I don't
have to pay honestly honest otherwise I
would use the smallest one. Um
but basically we are going to do the
same thing. We are going to ask the
model to generate a video using the view
model. Uh the prompt I'm going to use
the same prompt as the one that we used
to to generate the image. And I'm I'm
passing the last generated image as uh
as a starting um frame. And then I want
to portrait and I want 720p because it's
going to be smaller. Uh and here we go.
So I actually haven't checked what the
sounds looks like because I
>> stand back. You shall not pass.
Leave this place little ones. You don't
belong here.
>> I think it's quite good. Um but sometime
it's not not very good because the model
doesn't like the the prompt was just
about creating the steel image and the
and I think and the model doesn't know
what's exactly is expected to be
happening afterwards. So a better way of
doing it is actually to reuse the chat
the chat to ask the model to come up
with the um with the uh with some
explanations about what's happening
after the image and I'm also passing it
the image again so that it knows exactly
which part of the of the chapter we are
talking about so that it can come up
with the with the right prompt. Um and
so it like it came up with this uh this
prompt mold shivers and clutters his
scarfs in terror blah blah blah. Uh
water brats bravely draws it glass and
step forward to protect him. So up we
can see how it goes
and some oh like it's like the the like
in this case the results are not really
as good. uh and uh yeah and every time
every every test I've done somehow when
I use the same prompt it's it add it's
add text and and not when I when when it
generates another another prompt but but
it should not have any impact because in
both cases I'm just giving a prompt and
giving an image but I don't know why
it's happening like that um
um and then we can use the new LIA model
that we generated like that we um
shipped last week uh to uh to create
songs for each model. So still the same
the same trick again. We are going to
ask the model to create the the prompts
for that. Uh and then I'm going we are
going to use generate content with the
laya model uh ask it to create uh song
uh thanks to the chap the the prompt and
that's basically it. So let's see the
first uh the first song should be
orchestral acoustic folk music peaceful
flowing acoustic guitar and and flute
duets. Let's see.
I think it fits. Then the second one,
the open road is uh jy adventurous
rhythmic with fiddle and acoustic bus.
And then the last one is suspenseful
creepy melody with stacato pizzicato
strings.
And I think it fits as well. And I I
honestly I think the the model is really
good because I it's not very often that
you can do those kind of demos without
actually checking what's what it's going
to be because I run the the notebook
before, but I didn't check what the what
the music were going to be looking like.
And that's uh so far it worked all the
time. Um one of the things that I s I
forgot to say about all of that is that
the way we are training our model
internally is that a lot of the training
data for the gen media models is
actually made using Gemini. So that's
the reason why Gemini is quite good at
generating those prone for the gen the
generative media models because it's
already trained on uh on understanding
what Gemini is asking for. So that's uh
that's what makes the Gemini very good
at at generating those um uh those
prompts. And then uh the last the last
model that I wanted to show is the
texttospech model. So I'm pretty certain
that you all have heard of this one
because uh everybody loved the uh
integration in Notbook LM where you
could create a um
um a podcast based on on your documents.
And that's basically the same model that
uh you can create you can ask it to to
talk uh to tell read and what the text
you you give it and you can have it you
can have two characters with different
voices and and so on. That's that's what
makes it uh like nice to listen to. But
what I wanted to show you is that there
are actually tricks to um to have more
than two voices actually. Um and uh and
the reason for that is uh I think Paige
showed that a bit but you can uh when
you're using text to speech or live you
can actually do a lot in the prompting
to make it speak in in different ways
with different accents with uh uh and so
on and we are going to use that to our
advantage to basically have more than
more than two voices in in the same um
in the same generation. So what I did
because I was lazy I would not do that.
it it was I wanted to do that at scale
but I basically asked it to extract one
of the dialogue from the book and then
to rewrite it as as a transcript of of a
play and to replace the name of the
character by nar narrator if that's just
a narrator talking and for all of the
others is are just going to be named
character but with a specific style for
each of them and if the same character
comes back it's it's going to reuse the
same style style so that it's going like
the same characters are going to have to
to speak the same way and have the same
voices.
Um, and then I'm defining the voices. So
the nar narrator is going to use Sulafat
voice whatever it is. And then the the
all of the others are going to share the
fener voice. Um, and then I'm just
asking it to uh to uh to generate the
thing. And just one trick here with the
TTS model, you always have to start with
read this or uh tell me this or
whatever. If you just send the text,
it's it's going to ignore it for some
reason. So, uh you you need to prompt it
to read the text all the time. And but
that's also where you can add some uh
some context and like equivalent of what
would be a system instructions like read
this in a scary way or the characters
are very excited. So that's where you
can you can add those details as well.
Um and so you can see the the the text
that we got is narrator is saying that
then the first characters is going to
talk very fast-paced and with a British
accent and posit accent um and then and
so on and we can see that the same uh
the same way of speaking is is coming
often. So it's when the two characters
uh going back and forth. So let's see
how it goes.
small, neat ears and thick, silky hair,
the two animals stood and regarded each
other cautiously.
>> "Hello,
>> hello.
>> Would you like to come over?"
>> "Oh, oh, it's all very well to talk." He
spoke rather pettishly, being new to a
river and riverside life and its ways.
The second animal said nothing, but
stooped and unfassened a rope and hold
on it, then lightly stepped into a
little boat which had not been observed.
It was painted blue outside and white
within, and was just the size for two
animals, and the first animal's whole
heart went out to it at once, even
though he did not yet fully understand
its uses. The rower sculled smartly
across and made fast. Then he held up
his forpaw as his guest stepped
gingerely down.
>> Lean on that now. Then step lively.
>> To his surprise and rapture, he found
himself actually seated in the stern of
a real boat. This has been a wonderful
day. Do you know I've never been in a
boat before in all my life.
>> What? Never been in a You never Well, I
What have you been doing then? He was
quite prepared to believe it as he lent
back in his seat and surveyed the
cushions, the oes, the rollocks, and all
the fascinating fittings, and felt the
boat sway lightly under him. Is it so
nice as all that? Nice? It's the only
thing. Believe me, my young friend,
there is nothing, absolute nothing, half
so much worth doing as simply messing
about in boats. simply messing messing
about in boats messing.
>> Look ahead. It was too late. The boat
struck
>> basically you couldn't guess that it's
actually using the same voice for the
two characters. They are so much
different. And so that's that's that's
that's really actually a really cool way
of like uh creating those discussions
with multiple characters. So I can use
it. And uh the last thing is that uh as
we said like the Gemini models are
multimodel by by default. So I was I was
using a book uh but you can also send an
audio book or movie or some like not too
long movie but you could you could do
the same things with uh with using all
of the multimodel input possibilities to
uh to have Gemini create things uh for
to illustrate other um other kind of
modalities as well. Um how much time do
we have? Um
I I said I was going to show you the uh
realtime model. So this is a very good a
very cool example that Oh no stop.
I'm going to show you something be
before. Uh Paige made some example of
cool things that you can build in ICO.
So one of the thing I wanted to try was
basically to do the same thing as what I
do in the in the notebook which is kind
of lengthy and quite complicated stuff.
So what I did is I basically copy paste
it. Can you build an app that that
illustrates a book using gen media
models as described in this Python
notebook and I just paste all of the
content of the notebook and and build it
and we'll see how it goes.
um it can take quite a long time like
earlier it took 15 minutes so we you
might not want to wait for that but uh
we I can show you space DJ in the
meantime. So uh as I said the model
generates uh music in real time and this
is uh this is a a demo where they made a
a star like universe of stars and the
the planets are prompts. So if we go
closer to some planets it should start
playing music.
And then if you slowly somewhere else
Yeah. We Yeah. I guess in the middle uh
area.
See you. Uh I'm really surprised like
people are not doing more things with
this model because it's it's so funny to
go
and there's an autopilot so you can just
let it move around for for 10 minutes
and then uh listen to the music changing
in real time. Um that's kind of cool.
Up. Let's see how it goes here. Like,
yeah, it's thinking. But let me show you
what it what it did before when I ran
it. Oh,
and I I kept my laptop open for half an
hour just so that it would not do that
and refresh the page. So, I guess I
lost. Um, but that's basically what it
did in uh in uh like earlier just uh as
you can see just the prompt and nothing
more. a very long prompt
up uh and uh it took something like like
a thousand seconds so like 15 minutes if
I'm not wrong um to create the app but
that's basically doing exactly the same
thing so I can choose the file and
upload it and it's going to take some
times but basic like trust me it's doing
exactly the same thing uh as as what the
notebook was doing and that's really
like quite impressive that It's doing
that uh on the first try right away. Um
and just to finish I one of the thing
I'm doing when I'm vibe cutting uh while
it's working is that I always have those
uh instructions on how to get uh to get
it to generate um applets or apps. Uh,
and one of the reason for that is that I
want the apps to be as easy for me as to
review as possible because I want to
avoid exactly what happened to page
earlier that something was not working
and then you you need to figure out what
it is and ask the model to fix it. Um so
one of one of my key tricks is that I'm
asking the model to create different
files for each uh each feature so that
uh whenever I need to review something I
can quickly check like I ask it to
modify this feature it's it's updating
something that has nothing to to do with
it. So I know from the start that
there's something wrong going there and
I will be more for in the in my in my
reviews and all. And also some
instructions that I I don't understand
why it's not by default in any vibe
coding uh tool which is add logs because
when you need to uh when you need to
debug you you just know the error
message is not enough. You need to know
what's happening before and what's
happening like because you know you need
to know where where it's happening. So
that's uh I really recommend you to uh
to to use those kinds of of guidelines
whenever you you vodit things and we can
see how it goes now. Oh, and something
there. I don't think Paige showed it,
but if you are if you're willing to pay,
you can add an API key here and then you
are going to have more uh more kota to
use Gemini when when you are vi coding
on on AI studio.
Uh I think I will just let you show your
demos and maybe I can show you
afterwards how it looks uh after.
>> Yeah, sure.
for the video model when you generated
the video.
Is it using your models to generate that
or is it just
>> Yeah, it's just view at the moment. Is
there a way to
orchestrate all the models and put them
together or do you have to just use
those
generate?
>> Oh, if if you want to use the music
generated by Lia in the V the video
video for example. Uh no, you don't have
a way to do that. It's it's more it's
more because of the model limitations
that the VO3 generation was not meant to
be able to uh to ingest audio files. So
uh so that's why it's it's limiting. Uh
but I guess like the future is that we
want every model to be able to ingest
all modalities so that we you can you
can do that. Uh same thing I think uh it
would make sense even for Laria model to
be able to uh ingest audio models that
it can so that it can be used as
references as well or even if you want
to do multi-turn and say okay I love I
love your song but the the ending was a
bit uh uh not not epic enough so make it
make it more epic so that it would maybe
just just update the the end of it. So
yeah, it's not possible at the moment,
but that's the direction it's it's
going. Uh
>> performance really specific for the
music in Ven.
>> No, I
I wouldn't try VO for for any kind of
music like I the the the training data
for for the background music and like is
very is likely very light because it's
always doing the same kind of non-m
music things. Um so uh no but once again
all of those models are trained more or
less together uh and share some training
data. So I'm sure the next generation of
VO is going to be better at that. It's
just that the current one it it shipped
a year ago and a year ago there was pl
like we didn't have music generation
models like we talked earlier about text
in videos and uh and like a year ago
nano nano banana was not even called
nano banana it was Gemini 1.5 image.
2.0 image uh generation something uh and
it was uh it was not as good at as as
text. So that's uh yeah it's just uh
just a question of of generation of
models uh there.
Oh and I forgot something to uh while it
work um if you want to run the to run
the notebook uh because you will have to
remove it as well. Um
here here when I started yeah I created
the chat I I added this line that says
service tier priority. It's actually
something that we shipped last week. Um
and that's a way for to indicate when
you are prompting the models to if you
want uh if it's not that important you
don't you you don't care about the
latency but but you but you care about
price. So there's uh a service tier that
is called flex and basically that says
uh the the request can take a few
minutes to go through but it's going to
be alic. So it's kind of the same thing
as uh as using the batch API. And on the
other end, because I wanted to be sure
that certain that it would go through
today, you can you can say that it's a
priority request. So it's going to have
slightly higher priority and that uh it
should not uh it's it's going to be more
reliable, but you're going to pay twice
the price. So uh if you're running it by
yourself, you might want to remove that
line to save a bit. Um and we can see
how it goes here. Oh, and see as I said
like this model is in high demand. So
yeah, that's um I'm I'm sorry about
that. It's it's a the model is too uh to
uh too too good people everybody wants
to use it and we don't have enough
capacity. So if you have if you have any
spare TPU to uh to share um we can make
a deal. You have a question.
>> Do you plan to
put like variations of this model open
like general but for
art.
Um so the question like for the video
for the question is will will there be
any open weight gen media model
basically
>> um so I don't think so for image and
video generation uh to be honest um one
one of the reason I see behind that is
all of the um not sec like security but
like the um when when you when you
generate images or videos um we do a lot
of checks about what you are asking for
and what what is actually being
generated afterwards and we are blocking
a a couple of things that are not
aligned with our our visions and I I
feel like whenever you have an open
weight model for that it's it's more
like open bar and you can you can have
it generate whatever you want so that's
I think that's that's going to be where
our uh our company values are going to
be uh to be limiting us um that said for
example for music it would make sense to
uh like especially if you want real
time, it would make sense to be uh to be
uh to be on device so that it's it's
it's doing it faster. So that that's
something that might come at some point.
Um
cool. Yeah, I think we'll see after the
Gemma demos if uh if it works better. Um
yeah, hope it was interesting.
>> Thank you.
And so uh Ian is uh basically my my
counterpart. I work only on gen media
model. Ian is working on Gemma models
and he's going to like the biggest
release of last week was Gemma 4 and
he's going to show you how cool the
model is.
>> Thank you.
>> Yes. So as G mentioned, my name is Ian
Valentine. I'm a developer relations
engineer working on the gem models and
this is an impromptu talk. Uh we
obviously because of everything that's
happened today uh we've done Paige
mentioned that we've we're going to do
two sessions just kind of go through a
whole load of stuff. We have a number of
Gemma talks for the rest of the week as
well. Uh Omar is going to do a keynote
on Friday I believe which is going to
cover a lot of like the what gem is and
why you should be interested. So I'm
going to like speedrun that section. Um
and we have another talk tomorrow on uh
what we've called sovereign escape
velocities. So like how you take
ownership of AI and run things on your
device or on your own cloud or on phones
and hopefully some of what I talk about
here is going to be like a realization
of some of that. So that's a little bit
more about like the why. I'm just going
to show you the what it is. That makes
sense. So let's get plugged in while we
do that. Which one do I need? Sorry
for
>> this magic one. Yep. soon as I get a
video in.
>> You have any audio?
>> Uh, no. Let's go with no.
We'll try and show the ones without
audio first of all. Uh, okay. So, as I
mentioned, this is super impromptu, so
we're going to go with whatever we get.
Uh, but I will go through I'll just show
you a couple bits when we get the screen
up. Oh, do you need me to move it to one
side? Or can I do a mirror?
>> Let's do mirror.
>> Let's do mirror. Uh,
where? Yeah, you go for it.
Perfect. Yeah. So, what I'm hoping to
show you a little bit is uh you know
some of the things that uh some of the
devices that Gemma models can run on.
Like I'll talk very briefly about the
different size of Gemma model uh what we
released in Gemma for last week because
it's brand spanking new. Um and
hopefully show you give you kind of a
feel of like the kind of capabilities
that you can now do either locally or
that you can run on like a single GPU
that maybe you couldn't like six months
ago. There you go. Here we go. Perfect.
Tada. So, Gemma 4. Hooray. Uh, so this
was released last uh Thursday. Um, it's
a family of four models. So, we have
what we call the effective models, the
E2B and the E4B models. And these are
models designed to run like on mobile
phones, Raspberry Pies, Jets, and Nanos,
kind of like very small low-end
hardware. Uh, the E part of it is the
question we always get asked. The
effective is uh because the model
architecture has a per layer embedded
structure which means that the
embeddings actually don't need to be
loaded as part of the model. So you can
have them running on flash um and then
you can page in uh the embeddings as
they're needed for the model. So the
actual what we kind of describe as like
the brain of the model is about a two
billion parameter about four billion
parameter but if you put all of it in
RAM it's a bit bigger than that. It's
kind of more like a five and an 8
billion parameter model. Um so that's
why it's called effective 2B. Uh we also
have a 26B which is a mixture of experts
model with 4 billion activated and we
have a 31 billion parameter dense model
which is our like our flagship kind of
big model. Um and both of the two bigger
models the 26 and the 31 are designed to
be able to run on like laptops and
desktops or like single instance GPU
clouds depending on like the precision
and quantization you need. So, not going
to get into that, but just imagine that
a lot of the capabilities you can do
right now, you could do on like a
MacBook with, you know, enough RAM or a,
you know, a 5090 or something like that.
That's kind of where we're sitting right
now. Um, why are these kind of exciting
and interesting to us? Because with
these models, we're focusing kind of on
the agentic side. So, they now have
thinking built in. They are multimodal,
so they can understand image, audio,
video. Uh audio by the way is just for
the two smaller models. The effective
models that run on the phone can
understand audio but the rest can
understand image and video. And we're
seeing uh performances offer models that
are in the range of like 10x bigger than
it in terms of parameter size. So what
might have required a cluster now you
could do same kind of capabilities for
uh for a single GPU. So that's kind of
really where we're seeing um some
innovation here. Um, and what I'm going
to jump straight into is I want to show
you the demo section. Oh, I I'll show
you this one slide. I I like this one.
This is quite kind of explains a little
bit where where we've come. So, the
Gemma 2 models, you can see like right
in the middle, we're kind of, you know,
particularly good at creative writing,
but uh uh not so kind of evenly spread
amongst amongst other different
capabilities. And as we've kind of gone
through Gemma 3 and then now through
Gemma 4, we've kind of evened out the
overall capabilities of the model. We've
got things that are much better at
coding, much better at function calling,
action taking is all kind of built into
the design of the architecture of the
model rather than relying on uh like
strong um instruction following
capabilities which we find with bigger
models is is kind of more important. So
the models are designed with that from
the ground up. So uh let's go over to
uh this is all spoilers from Omar's
talk. So I'm going to go straight to the
demo section here. I'll show you this
one. So,
this is the uh Google AI Edge Gallery
app. Uh has anybody tried this app yet?
Uh have uh one, two, okay, like a
handful of people. So, you can download
this on Play Store, App Store. Um it
works on Android and iOS. And uh what it
is is it's uh it's a way that you can
test and try the models. So, we released
a new feature called agent skills. And
what agent skills allows you to do is it
allows you to set up skills for the
models that run physically on the phone.
So this model, this is the E2B model is
running literally on uh a pixel I
believe in this case. And you can prompt
it and you can test out the different
capabilities. So it's effectively given
a set of um uh skills that define things
like Android intents where you can
actually trigger and call other apps or
you can write your own JavaScript skills
or like run like a web view and uh you
can instruct the model and it will make
a decision about how to actually trigger
these. So you can get it to for instance
add things to this uh research tracker
or you can ask it questions about the
research tracker and it will call the
correct function to pull that data back.
So, we've gone from like a world of just
being able to chat with it on your phone
to now that you can give it some more
ambiguous input and it's able to make a
decision about uh what functions to
call. Uh the next one if it plays. Yeah.
So, in this uh in this example, we've
got a number of different I'll show you
that one last. There we go. Uh a number
of different skills that you can try
out. So everything from just like you
know loading locations in maps to uh
like uh uh using APIs and other
services. Um so you can build these
things yourself or you can just use some
of the pre-loaded ones to try and
understand what it's kind of capable of.
And this is like our playground for kind
of doing so. And then lastly I wanted to
show that uh this is the 2B model on the
left hand side. So you can you could
also try things like vibe coding on
device. The model's actually quite
capable of doing this. You're not going
to build like you know a big
architectural system but it can do you
know small like web apps that
understands lots of different languages.
Uh you can write things in Python, HTML,
TypeScript. Uh it can validate some of
the stuff and uh you know you could
build like little apps that can run on
the on the phone itself. So you kind of
got the whole feedback loop just on in
the palm of your hand basically. So this
one they just generated like a really
simple calculator and importantly it
does actually support divide by zero and
gives an error correctly. So it's even
able to reason about those kind of
things and to uh to kind of add I think
this at the moment it's got with
thinking turned off but if you add
thinking turned on we see that you get a
bump in terms of the quality of the
output in term uh in terms of what the
model's actually able to reason about
because it adds that planning step
before it actually does the execution.
Okay. So, next I'm going to show you a
demo running on the device. Um, who here
has used or uses LM Studio or uh Olama
or any of those kind of tools?
Okay, so like maybe like three or four
people. Um, so actually this is useful.
So, one thing that's really important to
us when we build these models is making
it compatible with a lot of the tools in
the ecosystem. So we partner with uh
folks like Alama, LM Studio, VLM, SG
lang to make sure our models kind of
like work really well with them and that
they can be deployed efficiently. Um LM
Studio is kind of like uh a tool for
running local model instance. So in this
case, I'm just got the 26B model running
on my device and you can uh you can load
it from here and at the moment this one
is configured. This one will take about
uh at the moment it says seven 18
gigabytes but if you add for instance
the uh enough memory to do the kind of
context you're looking at be like 22 GB
uh of uh RAM required to do it. This is
an M4 Mac so obviously has unified
memory so you can you can run that but
you would need if you wanted like full
performance you'd need to have a GPU
with enough RAM to be able to run the
whole model. And as I mentioned, the 26B
model is a mixture of experts. So it uh
actually only needs uh 4 billion
activated parameters. So it's much
quicker than the 31B model, but it is
more intelligent than just a 4 billion
parameter model would be. So uh one cool
thing about this is that with these
models, you can serve them uh on your
local machine uh via a compatible
endpoint. So uh like an OpenAI
compatible endpoint or an anthropic
compatible endpoint. and then you can
use them with other apps. So what I'm
going to do here is I'm just going to
serve this model uh on port 1 2 3 4 and
then I can use other apps to call uh the
chat completions API directly on this
one. So the code to do this would be
like open AI uh open chat completions
and then point it at this server and it
would be the equivalent of just using
your local machine rather than using a
cloud machine. So I'm going to run a uh
terminal here. I'm gonna do demo SVG
space. So, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create uh one orchestrator
instance and then I'm going to create 10
sub aents and they're going to generate
SVGs for me. So, all they're going to be
told to do uh actually let me make sure
I turn thinking off to make sure it's
super fast. Uh glad I remembered that.
Right. So, each of these terminals here
is a separate agent. And you can see the
one the orchestrator is this one right
here. Uh so it's farming out those
decisions to all the different sub aents
and each of those sub aents has begin
been given a different thing to draw. So
you can see this will be like a very
good way for you to do some kind of
quick prototyping on your local machine.
Uh you don't need the internet to do
this. And the throughput in the corner
up there is how much combined token
generation is being done by each
individual um sub aent. So when they
finally put it all together, the
orchestrator will just compile this into
a page and you get like a lovely array
of different SVGs that they've
generated. So you can imagine this being
any kind of aentic task that you want to
be able to do on your machine. You know,
sorting out files, implementing bits of
code, doing like subdividing research,
analyzing data, that kind of stuff like
that. Um, and you can give them all very
different jobs to do this. So some of
them have finished already. That's good.
So something hopefully will pop up in a
second. There you go. So there are my
SVGs. So Oh, they're not too bad, are
they? And as I mentioned, oh, this one's
animated. A spinning planet. So it's
somehow fig figured out how to make that
look as though it's u animated, which is
quite cool. Yeah. And this is the
thinking turned off. So if I had
thinking turned on, it does a little bit
more thought in the planning stage, and
you generally get better SVGs out. Like
more time spent thinking about it
results in better SVGs.
Um, so the next thing I wanted to show
you is, uh, I'm going to jump over here
to open code. So, as I mentioned, uh,
you can use any application that can use
an open AI compatible interface. So, if
you've got like a programming
environment, uh, you can just basically
point it at that and you can try the
model out to just see how well it
performs. So, in this particular
example, the all you do to configure
this in open code is you just I'm going
to kill all my terminals here. by
goodbye.
Let's get rid of these. If you go to
there is a single file. If I go
vim.config
open code config.json
and I scroll down to
where is it? This section here. This is
all you need to specify. So you give the
name of the provider, what the schema
is, the models that you want to expose,
uh, and any additional parameters that
you need for the endpoint, and then you
just literally point it at a URL, which
in this case is just my local machine.
And that's all you need to do. And I
have another example. I'm not going to
run this right now, but we have a guide
for how you deploy Gemma for on say
something like Cloudr Run or like a
cloud provider. So if you don't have
enough RAM to run the the quantization
that you want, you can just throw it up
to a single GPU and you get this this
single command here, this one right
here, the beta cloud deploy, and this
will put the model on a an RTX Pro 6000.
So you can just if you just want to test
it out, that's one way that you can test
whatever model that you fine-tuned or
run yourself. And we have another way to
access it as well. If you go to ai.dev,
dev that uh Paige and Gim have been
showing you. We've also got the Gemma
models are available here. So if you
just want to prompt them, we've got the
two big models and you can test them out
there and they support like you know
video and file uploads, grounding with
search is all kind of built into that
too. So you can test to see how they
perform in isolation as well. So really
there's no reason whether you have the
hardware or don't have the hardware uh
for you to be able to give it a shot. Uh
yeah, what I wanted to show you was that
I had uh generated a spec for uh a
little game. Uh where is it? Okay, so I
made a game called Nebula Drift. So what
I did is I used the 31 billion parameter
model to give me just like a spec for a
game and I'm just going to give it to my
local model to go and implement. So if I
go implement
spec
uh and then I just give it the file this
one and uh sure it's the right model and
let's make sure we turn thinking back on
so that it's going to actually reason
about it too.
Uh there we go. Uh and we'll run that.
And so why is this interesting? Because
we haven't changed anything about open
code at all. We've just literally given
it the model to try on the local machine
and in the open code spec it's going to
give it all the different tools that it
needs to be able to run open code and to
behave in that environment. So it should
think about uh the task it needs to do
and then it needs to look at the file
system to either read files from the
file system or write files to the file
system and if it goes wrong I can
similar like to any coding harness I can
just prompt it and say oh did you check
this or can I feed the error back into
you and have it kind of reason through
it. So this is just it following these
instructions. So yeah it's decided to
make a directory. So it's going to use
the shell directly directory from that.
So, if you've used any coding tools,
this shouldn't be too uh unfamiliar, but
maybe you've used it with another model.
Maybe you haven't used it with a local
model or an open model um like running
on your hardware. So, I just want to
show you that this is kind of possible.
Oh, yeah. There you go. It's already
created an index file. That was quick.
Um it's going to create, if it reads the
spec correctly, it should generate two
more files. It should generate a
JavaScript one and a CSS one. Uh and
then what we'll do is we'll just try to
see what game it managed to make from
the spec. Um, and to kind of give you an
idea, it should be like a an infinite
racing game where you've got to avoid
some asteroids. So, if it finishes off
the code,
um, there we go. Should we give that a
shot? That looks like it's actually done
something correctly.
So, if I go run that, where did it write
it? What was it called? Nebula. Oh,
Nebula drift with an underscore.
decided. Oh, I think it's even trying to
change the file path as I look at it
right here. It's trying to make edits to
it. Stop. Stop editing. Um, so let's
just try and run that. Okay, we have a
game.
Uh, oh, it doesn't run. Okay, so this is
interesting. So, what we can do is if we
just go
uh
let's try and run that again. Ah, so
there's a syntax problem. So if I say if
I just literally copy this. So imagine
in most harnesses you'd have a feedback
loop where you could feed it back
straight into the coding. But I'm just
going to do it manually and see if it
can spot its own error. I uh stop.
I found
an error.
Let's check that.
Did you actually read that or not? Let's
try again.
Okay, so now it should now it should uh
do some investigation. So probably
reread the files, see if it can spot
what the typo is or what the problem is
and then it would should try and edit it
or fix it. So actually in open code they
give you two tools. One which can edit
like individual lines and one that can
just like rewrite the file. So it it can
even make a decision about which one of
those it needs to use to do it. Uh so
hopefully it's going to edit it
correctly. Um and then write that back
out. So it's updated the game jet.js
and it's editing
uh
what are you editing something else? Oh
um it can also kick off sub aents too.
So if you give it like a specific skills
or task to do, it can basically uh run
sub aents. Uh the 31B is pretty good at
that. The 26B depends like on the task.
Sometimes it understands like what sub
aents to call and sometimes you have to
give it a bit more prompting. But
similarly with an environment like this,
you can expose MCP servers, you can
create skills, you can do all sorts of
stuff to kind of like help guide the
model. Um, should we see whether that's
fixed anything?
There we go. I don't even see. Did that
refresh?
Nope, not yet.
It's trying to edit the game file.
Must match exactly. So, okay. So, it's
trying to edit a part of the file. I
could also just say like,
uh, null. Okay. I think it probably got
unloaded. Let's put that back in. Let's
load that back up.
Try again, Gemma. Right. So, if I tell
it just output the full file again
for game.js.
Uh,
where did it put it? It was in that one.
So you can tell it like specifically
which file it should be reading and
writing to. So hopefully it should
listen to what I say and then uh
regenerate that file.
While we're waiting, does anybody have
any other ideas for a game to to make?
Paige is obsessed with like pink
squirrels, but like so you could try
something in that vein. Any any ideas
for a game?
>> A game where you can build your own
game.
>> Whoa. Let's try it. So, I'm gonna use a
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Let's go ask. We'll ask the big
model. So, if I go uh Okay. Write a spec
for a game where you can build your own
game inside the game
and
use this as a reference. So, we're going
to build a spec first. Uh let's just go
here and we'll use
Yeah, we'll use we'll use the spec for
the other one as a reference.
Let's try and run that
while we see what's going on with our
open code.
This looks like it's editing the file
right now.
Yeah, you can see it's processing the
tokens right there.
If I go to this one,
OmniForge.
So, what it's what I've done here is
I've told it to follow a particular
spec. Uh, so it keeps the same pattern.
So, like for instance, if I had like a
format that I needed it to do in, it's
pretty good at following those
instructions and kind of keeping to that
uh that record. This may not be
impressive if you've used any model in
2026 other than to know that it's
something that you can actually run at
home. That's for me is the interesting
part of this like the you know all the
top models can do this. Uh but yeah up
until recently not not that you could
run yourself. So uh let's leave that
doing its thing there. Has it fixed my
file yet? It's made more edits. We can
go and see what it changed. So it's
starting
Oh, it added some more
delta time. Oh, it's changing the input.
Okay. Okay. Well, you can see what it's
generating here. Like it's got like
these little player cases and all sorts
of stuff. Should we see if it runs
again? Uh, while we're waiting for that,
right?
Are you going to run yet?
Ah, you what I could do is I could just
say to it, um,
uh, let's say,
pressing the button
doesn't start the game.
Regenerate the files.
And hopefully it's just going to write
them back out.
Let's do that.
Okay, thinking about it. See how our
spec is getting on. So, let's just get
31B. Can you just implement
this spec
uh but as a single index.html
with the CSS and JavaScript
included.
See that it can do that.
Okay.
Uh, and there's one other thing I want
to show you. We'll do that in parallel.
AI.dev. One thing that the model is
actually quite good at doing being
multimodal is to understand um the
context of the input that it's given. So
I could for instance take uh a
screenshot of a website
like uh if I go to
Gemma for deep mind.
Let's go to this one. And if I just go
like uh
I just grab this
and I could just go to the model uh
implement this web page
web page as a single index.html.
If I just upload that file
that one. There you go.
and try and run this.
Yeah.
How's our open code getting on?
So, it's written the game file hopefully
with no mistakes. Written the style file
and hopefully written the index file.
So, let's give that another whirl.
Right.
There we go.
So, there's our game except I don't see
any asteroids.
Okay, we've got a starfield and we've
got a movable ship. So, again, this is
just what the model has come up with.
You could just iterate on this. You
could kind of add to it. Uh I'm not
going to I could ask it for more
asteroids, but I think we're done with
this one. Uh let's see how the other
ones are getting on. So, this is the
this is the game about making a game.
I'm really curious just to see how what
it does for this because that's going to
be pretty nuts. And then this one,
this is generating the Oh, yeah. This is
generating the recreated web page. So,
uh this is all free to to play around
with. Um so, just be aware there's like
usage limits in terms of like like
shared ownership. Um but you can just
use it like to test stuff out pretty
easy. Uh that's why it's a little bit
slower than the um the Gemini models
because it's the uh there's only one
poor Gemma model serving everybody. Um
let's see. Is this one done yet? Still
going. I don't know. Maybe it's made
like a really epic adventure. I think it
might just be this might be, you know,
ship it as soon as this is done.
Uh what else I want to show you? Oh,
okay. While we're doing that, I want to
show you this cool demo. So, one of our
team uh is really into their robotics.
So, they uh they made a version if
you've ever used um any of the robot
simulation tools. So, this is called
Open Duck uh which is just like a little
simulator of duck and you can ask it
questions or you can talk to it via a uh
the E2B model which is running in the
browser. So, it's you don't you actually
download the model and it runs in web
GPU straight in the browser page. So
when it tells it to do these actions,
Gemma is interpreting like what it's
asked the model to do. It looks at what
the the robot can do and instructs it
to, if you look really carefully, you
can see where it says perform action.
Yeah. Before it actually does the
action, it tells you what command it's
trying to trigger. So you can imagine
this actually running embedded on the
device or in this case is in the
simulator to just like kind of like
prove the point. Um, so that's quite a
cool one. The other one uh I want to
show you was uh the Android Studio team
have integrated it into making Android
apps. So you've got like a little chat
window at the side and you can uh build
the apps from there. So they again they
have like a little aentic builder setup.
Uh so if you were just building phone
apps, you can um use the model. I think
they're using the 26B again. Yep,
they're using the 26B for that one. And
then uh we also have it working with um
the uh ADK. So our agent development kit
again it exposes like different
functionality. It's got a thinking loop.
It's got like a like a feedback system.
So you can give it more longer running
task and it can make decisions about
like pulling information and stuff like
that. So all these different
environments that you can kind of run it
in. Should we see how our find? Okay,
this one is done. So, this is going to
be this will be our web page.
Oh, that's not bad. That looks pretty
good. I don't imagine these buttons go
anywhere, but for uh what's new. Oh,
they I thought I literally thought it
had made a video. That would have been a
bit in that would have been a bit
intense. But yeah, but you can see even
just from like the layout, it's pretty
close. It's kind of matched the font
correctly. The understanding of the
actual page is pretty good. And this is
just kind of oneshotted. So, point it at
random web pages and see what it can
build. And let's see whether this I'm I
am now really interested in this game.
Let's see whether this actually works.
Oh my gosh. Right. Is this Oh, I've got
like a full editor.
So, I can build like a little Oh, I like
that.
So, a goal. Can I run the game? Uh, I
can put things in. Oh my gosh. Please
tell me that. Oh, yes. The triangle
moves. Oh, I love it.
Why?
Okay, there you go. That's that's a good
point to end on, I think. So, yeah, uh
Gemma models, uh you know, they run on
your phone, they run on your laptops,
they run on GPUs. Uh go try them out,
try the AI gallery if you want to
explore. Uh I'll be around today and
tomorrow if you have any questions about
how uh but yeah, uh really excited to
share that with you and uh enjoy the
rest of the conference.
because